hear me even at the back is it clear
enough yes okay thank you so I hope you
had a very good lunch and welcome to a
workshop today about test-driven develop
month and pepper gramming so make odor
okay so here's the Wi-Fi code we're
gonna need it
so please connect to this one and if you
haven't given your github user name
please do so now at the desk over there
we needed to add you to a github
repository to be able to push later on
some logistics so there will be there's
some snacks over there and some drinks
so if you hungry or thirsty please help
yourself on your table there is some
goodies from Paulo eighty so you have
notepad you have a pen and metallic
straws so this is for you and we're
gonna tee we're gonna be taking some
photos today so if you don't like to be
taking pictures please reach out to
chris go is chris over there that you
don't want picture taken from you that's
pretty much it for logistics so let's
start so welcome as I said about TBI
program until a so this gonna be
incorrect it trajectory workshop so for
beginners so I hope there is not all of
you are not all experimental II to that
if not if yes maybe you'll learn some
new things
so today agenda so we're gonna start
with our check-in then we can I give
introduction to test-driven development
we can introduce to you a report - ball
you're going to see why later on then
set up your machine to be able to do the
exercise and I'm gonna do a quick demo
of test-driven development then it's
going to be your turn to do the exercise
so we're gonna maybe forty forty-five
minutes of exercise with EDD then a
small debrief altogether and then we can
have a small break about ten minutes
after the break we're gonna do the same
with programming
first introduction then a small demo and
then you're gonna do the exercise for
about one hour then I can debrief and
we're gonna conclude with some resources
today with me so my name is Kevin take
me that Paolo i t I can so agile coach
at Paolo IT a mall full stack developer
engineer madaba DevOps and cloud
engineer and Nathan or a full stack
engineer and where is Anil at the
reception desk full stack engineer as
well at Paolo IT so party I don't know
how many of you heard about this company
we are consulting company international
with the development we have ui/ux
agile and DevOps and cloud we about
11:15 Singapore so if you don't know us
just google it party that SG calm or
that combat SG and you find us and you
can learn more about us chicken so I
invite Ken for a chicken do Mike
[Music]
we don't write any conferences where we
knew sister company vegan what we did is
to get a sense of their experience with
unity and your experience with learning
so we can go to this website work that
what men do not use the policy
which is
[Music]
[Music]
stop so let's see we have a power
I know buddy
okay I think yes stabilized
[Music]
such as a way to pick up to measure this
one we were proceeding from the
that's okay time to pick up a specimen
that 24 percent of a gun
less than a year good for you and when
exactly do a check in the morning and
for a 6 percent and this
and for those six percent of
you change your life let's go one second
question help so what has been
Oh orange
after that
as I guess stabilized so that's before
and as much a very much
there are specialists all those who
deviate
I hope I'm innocent
why exactly did it and I can live with
it okay the studied and
the three persons who passed by before
that I don't know about you my
experience when you
[Music]
thank you can sew test-driven
development what it is so it comes from
extreme programming which comes from
agile so some of you know scrum I bet so
extreme programming is a different
branch of it so can our from the book
extreme programming applied wrote this
code writing test first keeps entropy
from destroying your code we write tests
then we write just enough code to get a
test pass no more that is the best way
to keep your code clean so what this
means is the idea is really to write a
small test small as possible and then to
write just enough code to make it pass
and so on and so on and this avoid your
code to become a mess and this gives you
a good structure in your code so as I
said this is the gospel of TDD but came
back came back another author of extreme
programming so write a little test that
does not pass compiling not compiling is
not passing as well so that's completely
fine we call this the red states so the
red states very important then we have
to make the test passed as quickly as
possible even if you have to write messy
code or committing sin we just start to
make it pass that's it this is the green
stage after that once it's passed and
green we eliminate the duplication and
we rewrite the code to make it nice and
clean this is called the refactoring and
then we repeat this steps over and over
until we arrive to a sex fast
satisfactory results again if you're
forget was TDD is remember this red
green refactor code make it run red and
green so writing a test at fail making
it pass it runs
and then making it right so we refactor
the test the test end the code to make
it clean and nice for the developer to
look at it some people have asked me
okay what is refactoring there is a lot
of answer to that so I invite you to
look at this website here it gives a lot
of example of what refactoring a lot of
example it is very good with scenarios
and when to do what just some examples
so very obvious that most of you do it
already is just putting a name on it so
you can extract the function you can
extract a variable introducing an
explaining variable you can rename a
variable for example you can introduce a
parameter object or replacing loop with
pipeline so those are just five five
examples amongst hundred or thousand of
them
now I'm gonna give the mic to madaba
over there so you can just look on this
side vallabha or good
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
for us to monitor of US Congress in
their test results
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Adama so the idea of the
dashboard is industry standards mode of
the clients or company they ask for 80%
or above of code coverage the idea here
is to show that TDD is quite easy to
reach that numbers if we do the opposite
meaning we write your code and then at
the end or I need to write my test it's
going to be very difficult to have clean
tests and to reach those 80% or you're
not going to write the test that needs
to be written so this is just a
dashboard to see ok it's very easy to
integrate in Jenkins and to show your
coworker colleagues or even management
ok my code coverage is Android or 80%
okay now I'm going to do a demo of what
I just explained before so I hope that
some of you know that fizzbuzz exercise
who knows it we have three four five
okay so this is a very famous exercise
that in interview been asked a lot so it
looks very simple I'm gonna show how to
resolve it in TDD way so if the input is
a multiple of three you return fees if
the input is a multiple of five you
return buzz if he's dropped three and
five you return fizzbuzz otherwise you
just return the number that was given as
input quite simple right
so
oh let me take a chair I'm gonna zoom in
no worries
so this is the code you're gonna check
out later for the exerciser so you can
see the package the reason is quite
simple we just have B ball for
transpiling we have just for the code
for the test and that's pretty much it
that's all we need you have a folder
with example that contain the basic
function and its corresponding test is
just for you to get the syntax because
some people are struggling just to get
the syntax of just whatsoever so we can
just copy and paste from there as a as a
guideline so coming back to the fizzbuzz
exercise I'm going to first create
fizzbuzz directory
and inside this one I'm going to create
two file so one for fees bills DOJ's
is going to contain my function and one
for my tests so by convention I'm going
to name it exactly the same the test the
GS
so on the right side here you will have
my code so let me zoom in can you nobody
read is it big enough at the back
so my function is bars take the input as
arguments
I'm gonna export
and that should be it and then I'm gonna
write my test so I'm just going to copy
and paste from the example to go a bit
faster
[Music]
up here
[Music]
input so this is the name I choose to
give to my input so fizzbuzz that's
pretty much it
look sorry
okay let me move that to the left okay
difficult to go that big okay so I'm
gonna describe my taste treat so
fizzbuzz testing sheet and I'm thank you
I'm gonna start by so
[Music]
sorry
just
look my bad yeah there's something wrong
there oh sorry yes
sorry bending too much Java lately okay
so it should should written one when one
given a simple so I expect
given one to be one so this is the
simplest step I can think about at the
moment so if I run it
we can see it's failing so now I'm in
the red state now the next step is to
make it run so making green as fast as
possible so I'm gonna do written one
I'm gonna make a green as fast as
possible is green now I'm in the
refactor so refactor I think for now
it's okay
I don't need to refactor there is not
much code now next one next test so what
is the next test that will fail my code
so show written to when to given so
input to to be to okay
I'll run again and of course you'll be
red you fail so now again I'm the red
state so now to make it past as fast as
possible
if too
return - sorry it's an integer
[Music]
my pass so I'm fine I'm going to
refactor now no I think I'm good so far
so let's continue so now next one that
we fail if I continue this way so now
three three shall return fees
again I'm running my tests it should
tell which it does and again
if input three return fees with upper
case hopefully in pass so I mean the
green state so now I can refactor a bit
okay I prefer to have those brackets
with nicer and here I can over else with
some brackets
and though I like my refactoring I run
my test to ensure that it still pass
okay I didn't break anything with my
refactor now what's the next test that
will fail my code so sure return for
well forgiven so input for to be for
I run my tests and again I'm in the red
state I hope you are doing all of the
noon I'm gonna go 200 like that so now I
mean the red state so again to make it
fast so what for
return for
and now we pass okay now I can save a
tenancy whenever I have a number except
three to return this number as a string
so I can see there's a repetition so it
makes sense now for me to rewrite my
code in a better way so if it's not
three basically I need to return the
input of the string I'm gonna do it this
way and this I can remove and this I
will remove
now I'm gonna run my test again and it's
raining so my refactoring didn't break
anything
now the next test that will fail my code
will be 5 so 5 and return buzz remember
if it's multiple of 5 I need to return
buzz
so when input is 5
I expect buzz so again if input 5
returned but with appliqués
he passes can i refactor something now
yes maybe I would like the else here
make it nicer and maybe a test I can
refactor a bit better I would say now I
can sell at the tenancy before when I
give a number I should give this number
as a string as output so I would like to
refactor as Fritton
the input number when not multiple of
three and five given so I have two here
I have four as well
so now I can delete this one and I can
delete this one and now verse to ensure
that everything pass so I said before
refactoring is not only on the code side
it has to be on the test side otherwise
you get a mess very easy code is
important but test is as much as
important as the code now next one that
can think of to make it my code fail
will be 6 so 6 need to written fees
multiple of 3 so input work
sofie's
now I'm gonna make runs you should fail
and here so he put three or input
equal 6
so now I can see I have like if that
tend to be lengthy that we start
increasing so I decided to refactor now
I can see like so a multiple of three so
if my input modulo 3 equal equal zero
because it makes sense for me now to
refactor this pot who live test that
tells me to do it I written fees ensure
that I didn't break anything ok till
pass now I continue
so next one that can fail them so
written multiple of 3 so 9 no it will
not fail so be the next 110 multiple of
5 so input 10 show written buzz again
I'm a kid run so I'm gonna be in the red
state now I'm gonna be in the green
state but making it past as fast as
possible so or input equal 10
and I'm in the green state again same I
can see I met the man she is going to
add more condition in the if closed
so I'm going to refactor that so 5 equal
equal zero so to ensure that whatever
it's a multiple of five are written buzz
I'm gonna read it again and here I'm in
the green state so can i retract us
something maybe my test I can see here
the 6 3 5 10
so here social written fears when
multiple of 3 given
in same year so between birds when
multiple of five given
now I can delete those and I will run to
make it sure I didn't break anything
okay still green know what's the next
test I can write to make it fail
remember the multiple of 3 & 5 she
written fizzbuzz so it's written
fizzbuzz when multiple of when I would
say when 15 given so when I give 15 I
need to run fizzbuzz to return feasible
sorry I run and I should be in the red
state now again if input equal equal 15
return fizzbuzz
okay lies green now can refactor again
now use the else because I find nicer
that's all I can do at the moment
solvent again and I didn't break
anything
now next test that can fail 13 so
fizzbuzz went that they given so 30
should be fizzbuzz can run my test again
and i'm in the red state I'm going to
dust or input 30 written fizzbuzz I'm in
the red-green state now I can refactor
so again I can see a tendency of
repeating is still gonna increase the
more tests I add so I'm gonna do that so
15 equal equals zero or written fizzbuzz
okay pass now I'm still not satisfied
because the the statement says is
multiple of 3 & 5 so I prefer to do it
this way with my hand here because like
that when the developer read the code he
can say ok multiple of three and
multiple of five so it's clear as well
to understand
it still pass now again I'm going to
refactor my code my test so I'm going to
group these two together for multiple of
three and five
so shut up is buzzed when multiple of
three and five given I'm going to run my
tests and everything is green now if I
continue I cannot think about any test
that will fail my my code so I decide
that I don't have in fact not to do I
could do a bit more I can extract viable
I can do a name viable I can create sub
functions but I think for the purpose of
the demo now I think I'm good enough I'm
happy with that so I can push and commit
my code now if you look at the result of
the test here then i zoom in no other
way if everybody can see that it's a bit
small right so just to explain what I
mean by just by reading the test you can
tell what the code is doing if you just
read that you can you can you know what
the code is doing so show return the
input number what not multiple of three
and five year on sheraton feels when
multiple of three given show written
bursts when multiple of I given sheraton
fizzbuzz when multiple of three and five
given so just by reading this do you
know what this is doing without reading
the code and this can be understood by
everybody not only developers so this is
a big advantage of 3d and writing proper
tests as well okay I'm good for the demo
so let's go back to the flight
so how is this useful so he helps to
understand the problem statement and I
say that rather than coding directly the
whole problem it you have to break it
down to very small pieces
it looks steadiest at the beginning but
once you get used to it it brings a lot
of advantages and m to resolve more
complex problem easier it gives a better
design because every line of code you
write is because a test tell you to
write it and not because you want to
wait for any kind of reason it helps of
course define the current state of the
system behavior and it gives you a full
suite of tests to ensure system sanity
meaning by having this I have like
hundred percent of like coverage so I
ensure that my my code is tested so
nothing will break it and I got
regression test as well with that ok now
I don't know if you have any questions
so far about the demo something that was
not here otherwise you move on to you
pad so now it's your turn
ask you to close the following report so
we added you on the github so you should
have access to this one if you have any
issue with that let us know so as a
reminder there is a mural with ABBA any
turn Anil Kien and myself that can help
you with that so once you check out the
repo please create your own branch with
the following naming so TDD slash your
name or user name or you decide then you
can open the code in your favorite IDE
and run just npm install to have just
and everything configure on your machine
once this is done I give you maybe say
2-3 minutes should be enough then a
lecture to continue
[Music]
[Music]
not sure
[Music]
I know that now as Pakistan whether the
bus it could be shy
so I urge you not to be trying to just
stop whistle and feel miserable country
and the other thing is why we are doing
this in our workshops we also realize
that participants when they tried is not
they are not really moving in the slit
in each time to my diploma a test just
one test passing and the done now the
goal of this time is for you to try out
the steps activity if you skip our steps
and not ask a question and just get
I'm done I think when we see the point
of the workshop so it's okay to struggle
is okay to struggle
it's okay ask questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who still more time to do the those tats
who is not finished yet
raise your hand okay one two minutes
okay
but good yeah okay so I continue so just
some guidelines for the exercise try to
push every I would say five ten minutes
that we can see the result on a
dashboard directly we have a bell over
there so I'm just gonna ring a bell as a
reminder because sometimes when you lock
into your code you don't think about it
so the bells for pushing your code we
have two comments for you so NPM run
tests to run the test in the terminal
the console and NPM run coverage will
run the test coverage in you in your
console so you see a nice table with a
line branch and all the coverage
possible there okay so just before we
start the exercise reminder so TVD red
green refactor if you look at a cycle
during the demo is very fast so each
cycle is maybe one to two minutes so I
don't write code during 10 minutes then
write a test during five minutes so
should be very fast so short try to
break to break it down to very small
step so this is the point of DVD and
this is what's difficult okay
as Ken said it's okay to struggle we
here to help so this is the exercise
forget about the timing so the inputs in
this case sentence so she sells
seashells by the seashore it can be any
sentence not not only this one the
output is an object or you decide what
you want or string we let you decide
that will count the words it's case
insensitive so in this case every word
appears once except see that at least
two times and one with the upper case
but Alice case insensitive we count it
as two as I say this is an example every
sentence should be through you should be
working don't take it to account weird
characters like come out or like
estimation mark question mark on things
just space and characters
okay any questions for that so good luck
and we're going around and just raise
your hand if you stuck sorry
this one
and that means we had an empire
position okay
[Music]
I don't even know them every five minute
yes I do know so just a venting so
lettuce telling me that some of you
didn't accept the invitation from the
github so maybe check your email and you
have to accept it to be added to the
group
doing the exercise right end up doing is
but now we're going around and twelve
them
hope you discussed well of all the
feedbacks now if I can ask one
representative of each table can just
share with the others about your
discussion and if you have any question
just please ask us and we try to answer
them can we have a mic raise the mic
where is the microphone sorry Oh
so who wants to start please don't be
shy
[Music]
okay
okay so if a small was breaking down the
problem in small part that you are the
difficulties right okay yeah to address
this is I would say the most difficult
in TDD is to be able to see the problem
and breaking down in very incremental
small step so that's all the magic I was
in TDD what takes time to get so it's
all about practice yeah next one
shame
yes yeah okay so that's a tricky
question I would say but it's some kind
of rule let's say that every time you
have like a condition that repeat three
times or you can see three tests that
fulfill the same condition then is the
right time to group them together and
have some logic so that's one of the
rule now sometimes you can get you can
take a bit shortcuts I would say if you
hit logic and okay that's obvious
then you can take shortcuts but those
like I would say that the rules you can
follow you work on
next one
who is that
ha
we
Oh
well
okay yeah that depends on how you
approach it is about the small step you
can take and the code you only write the
code when the test tells you to write it
basically there's no other choice and
what doesn't make sense if you have to
refactor everything that's fine
but as long as you have the two previous
tests that say okay that was the state
and it has to be like that so it up yes
what
that might hurt by Oh
for example about quality could just
check whether that is something that is
missing and that might have sought it
out
they're gonna demo later on programming
out to resolve this in TDD so maybe you
helped you saw what a step they're
taking yeah
[Music]
okay so a flood today is very basic I
would say with just small functions in a
real world when you have prediction
system it's way more complex but the
idea is still to break break down to a
very small function that are testable no
matter why is this function called an
API the HTTP or any other protocol then
you can mock this part
the idea is to isolate to function and
to simulate what's around you function
so then the idea is still valid for TDD
as long as you mock and you simulate
what's around the new functions should
still be tested in the TDY 3d way
you join you mock if you do with actual
data you have to connect the HTTP and
everything this for me is more like
integration test so you can still test
after a while but the idea of opposite
option is using personally I'm not a fan
of using mocking the second approach but
sometimes
[Music]
it is supposed to have we do think
unicycle second-class if whatever was
used to achieve this means and your
tests are running past
No okay remember
confidence when you write so usually
before
and then
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so now we don't the TDD part so I
suggest we do a small break about ten
minutes and then we're going to start
with the pepra gramming part of the
workshop so don't forget there's some
snacks over there drinks so see you in
about ten minutes so what time is it now
it's 36 so at 45 see what modified we
start so the second part of this
workshop is about pair programming and
just do a quick sound check the last day
butter can you hear me you can okay
before I even dive into this topic let
me just say one thing to those who have
voted the pathway say I've done it and I
hate it all right
this session is not to convince you you
love it
Barada is really to ask you questions
about have you considered certain
aspects of pair programming when you are
doing it were those things present maybe
because those things are not present
that's why it makes you uncomfortable
maybe it's because of those so try to
consider put that into a part of our
things that you want to think about me
all right
okay well start we've came back as you
guys probably know when it comes to a
pair programming when it comes to
test-driven development these are all
extreme programming the alcohol extreme
programming and so there's another quote
he said this thing if code reviews are
good if code reviews are good we review
code all the time and that the thinking
behind that is this if if certain things
are good why are we not doing it all the
time one example is if testing is good
why are we not testing all the time that
is why introduced test-driven
development tests all the time so now
when we come to the topic of pair
programming
if code review is good why are we not
reviewing all the time and as where is
practice comes from now I don't know how
many of you guys everyday when you wake
up you go to work you wrote you look
forward to review other people's code
you look forward to approve a pull
request how many of you guys enjoy doing
them okay very nice for the rest of us
mortals we probably don't like and
sometimes the problem is this somebody
write some code you have no clues or
contacts and you just got a pull request
you look at a code and the best you can
do at that point in time is what you do
syntax check how much value is that and
if you're in a hurry you check the
syntax nothing seems to be
serious all those now cases I handed so
just accept that but a favorite pair
programming is it allows you to do code
review on the fly and I will explain it
a bit more later now this is what pay
programming is and what pair programming
is not I hope this doesn't clarify for
you guys
I noticed quite heavy of misconception
let's start with the left side the white
one
first of all pair programming is not
paying two persons to do a same thing
when a manager or where someone outside
we look at two programmer city together
do something you may assume that they
are doing that but in reality when it
comes to programming the fact that you
type right is actually not what you do
most of the time
it's thinking through logic trying to
figure things out that is why you do
most of the time so pair programming is
not paying to person sitting or keyboard
just typing is not it's about on the
right side it's like investing in better
software quality and design I do notice
even earlier on when we do a TDD some of
you guys already are collaborating
talking to each other already
now when you face such a simple problem
in this workshop and you're able to
collaborate
what more when it comes to writing
production code why shouldn't we call a
bit in that manner second some people
would think pair programming is only
good for training in other words Oh a
newbie just join our company let's pair
and most a newbie can fly leave him
leave him and let him do on its own
stuff but pack away is also about
complementing each other's strengths and
with and knowledge right today you may
be working on this part of system the
other person another part then the next
day when both of you comes together you
have knowledge about your entire system
even more because two persons are
working together you complement each
other some people thinks that pay
programming works well only for a small
number of people
that may be something that instinctively
we may think so especially those who of
us who haven't paid before you may think
that well I don't like to someone to be
looking over my shoulder but those who
have tried pepero gramming surprisingly
works well for majority of people i'm
not saying for everyone for majority
I've seen some cases where it's just
it's just not possible to pay program
well if that person okay but it works
well for majority I hope today over here
is the majority part pair programming is
just it's not just code and syntax
review by the partner so you have two
person sitting one person typing the
stuff the other person and the left just
look at all the syntax and correcting
order syntax if you did pair programming
in the past and that is what you do just
do syntax check I am calling that
suffering in silence because it's very
boring just it dance in distract but
rather pair programming is a context
which review and collaborative design
activity which also means that when
someone chose to write code in a certain
way since you are around you have the
context on why that things being done
that way and if you feel otherwise
immediately you are able to comment
because you have a context and like way
do a pull request you just review so
much thought you may not have order
context so this is why program is also
quite effective in a sense gives you a
context rich review the last two things
is you have to pay for everything
some people feel that wow my team is
doing pair programming I don't like it
because the moment I stepped in office I
must be pairing someone else until the
moment I leave the office or even cases
like I just want to try our serve the
dates on the play of so the technology
what you mean I must hire someone to do
that no usually the recommendation is
minimally should parent production code
in other words the code that you write
they will end up being in production
systems you should at least minimally
parent that and the last thing is no
more individual time it's similar to
what I've just said the moment instead
of office you must start pairing ready
even when I check my emails repair reply
to other people I must pay as it it
doesn't mean that you can consider this
thing called call pairing hours your
team can agree to say that when we do
pairing a production code we can start
pairing from let's say 10:00 a.m. to
12:00 then take a lunch break that may
be tree to 5:00 the rest of our time you
can do the rest of things that you need
to do
okay I'm pressure none of us here have
this luxury of outgoing the office and
just start coding right there's always
meat things and all these other things
but if you have a core paring hours you
could focus on writing a code the
restaurant IMing and do the other things
that's required of you okay
terminology it is important to clarify
the terminology because going forward
I'm gonna keep using this was what is a
driver a driver in pair programming is a
person who's typing on a keyboard or
holding on to the mouse that is the
driver okay you're the one who typed the
person sitting next to you in the past
is top partner that's a partner it's
nothing wrong to call partner but I've
also noticed that the terminology
Navigator comes out in play and never
again if someone sits next to you and
paraview yet at the same time try to
think about what are the scenarios that
you may need to cover you handle in your
code okay so the partner or the
Navigator works with your driver
together I'll be using these terms
interchangeably as we go along right so
this one we're gonna do a pair
programming demo in fact I'm actually
quite happy that most of you are still
around because some people say pay go
away I don't wanna leave already by
listening area try it out okay
for a demo before I demoed that I need
you to find someone to pair with because
you're going to try there as well first
introduce your name and what is your
favorite programming language
find a partner first all right I'll give
you one minute sure we have to find okay
start looking for
for those who don't have a partner
we have people who is ready to pay
review our naydon our new movie won't be
available yet
okay now the next thing is the next
thing is between the two of you decide
who's left top will be used
okay decide whose laptop will be used
because you've been using one laptop as
a payer is only one laptop
okay we're gonna move on now right the
reason why I asked you guys to pay up
now is because later on when you
actually do the pairing to write a
program you have to watch out for this
thing and this my guide Hitchhiker's
Guide on how not to pay program not to
pay program okay
and in order to demonstrate this I
invite my oscar-winning actors Armel and
Kevin what Egger do is they would show
you a scenario you have to observe the
scenario after that you tell me which
one from 1 to 5 which one of it that
they are doing okay what is the
dysfunction that they are showing all
that clear so I'm going to ask them to
start press alright
right
okay stop all right which one is it
second one quiet Quincy and disengage
then which one is the quiet Quincy and
which were disengage then
huh
yeah
you mean Elmo is quiet okay yeah what's
happening is Kevin wasn't talking very
much when he caught and a moody try to
engage but in the end he gave up that's
why I pulled out his hand when I saw
something
okay before I even comment on that let's
go on to the second scenario okay okay
guys ready
[Music]
okay stop which one is it
sorry so I see hugging
huh five hasty Henson no that's not one
right just wrong
and is it right yeah right just won't
this will be the kind of person when
you're caught you always think you're
the only one who knows the answer it can
happen but in fair programming you have
to be open to listen to other
suggestions and that's from a
perspective of the driver the person who
types
now sometimes is a person the navigator
who thinks or the partner who thinks he
or she is the right one no you're doing
this wrong oh this is wrong right pay
program is a collaborative work so both
sides needs to learn to collaborate in
that sense okay ready with the scenario
[Music]
okay stop what is this what is for Dirty
Harry is it right okay not a signal I
think in terms of our own way our
tidiness or how clean that impacts paper
wearing a lot I used to pair with
ex-colleague in the past before you
start sparing you always take an alcohol
wipe to wipe the keyboard and to what
the mouse then only we start pairing I
was laughing at him and say why are you
doing all these things we are clean then
you tries to prove the media is not
clean how by taking a keyboard flipping
it upside down petting and all the
crumbs that Fossum keyboard comes out
now and sometimes the theory can occur
where you eat oily food right now paper
or gaming the same you can eat football
someone call right there were hands oily
you start to grab keyboards are typing
they'll give back their partner this guy
thinks hygiene we have to watch our for
right ok next one
yeah
okay stop so that's a bit Oh acting but
okay what is it why is it three or five
this actually which eyes it honking
Henry yeah when we get in we have this
thing called the fluorite as developers
we get into the flow and some time we're
going to a flow we just don't people
this stuff what would be helpful in that
case is to have a certain comment
understand it before you start so that
if you're in a you know in a flow let
your partner to do it or if you feel not
covered at least talk about it
beforehand all right one last one last
thing
no no prize for guessing there
[Music]
okay stop
that is hasty Henson yeah now there's
one thing is in psychology in
programming psychology is you need to
understand the person who is typing will
not always be the fastest to spot things
the person who's watching usually spot
things faster for example if you are
typing and you try to click on a menu
file open let's say let's say let's take
the example your pair will catch where
the menu is faster than you do sometimes
you just go see that's just psychology
it goes with this thing if you write a
code you open your bracket close the
bracket and you miss it usually your
pair will spot faster now when it comes
to pairing you have to be patient let
the driver take his or her time to
finish what is finished until you
realize he or she really forgot then you
went to make a note of that obvious
driver is struggling why the code
doesn't compile and you know there is
because of syntax error then you can
point it out okay so these are the five
dysfunctions on how not to program yep
thanks guys
well deserves a clap so from from that
end I like to move now into how then
should I approach my programming this is
what I would use golden rule the
programming is simply this do unto
others what you want em to do unto you
like treat others like how you want to
treat you and it's not a very difficult
skill some people call it kindergarten
skills since young we are taught to do
that so some suggestions this is an
incomplete guy okay this is an
incomplete guy because he doesn't your
you may have your own ways first one is
use we when expressing something that
may not be favorable you may be coding
and you find your pair is coding towards
the wrong direction when it's going to a
road direction you don't start to say
something like hey that's a stupid way
of going you're going a wrong way rather
than let's say I think we are going the
wrong way that brings in the team spirit
this is just a simple freezing but it
does help second point use I when
they're going that's tough for you your
pair maybe typing something and you
couldn't follow so what you would want
to do is say I'm sorry I cannot follow
what you're doing can you explain to me
the third one is the Navigator
can offer the drive and a driver is
stuck or when unable to express an idea
verbally so you may be pairing a partner
and it's type he or she is typing half
way true realize he or she stopped but
you have an idea why not offer to take
all the keyboard and just say let me
show you what I have in mind or you
might have check are you stuck can I
help
so just take away start typing that's
how you swap pass sorry swap the rows
within the pack really quickly okay now
point four is driver's consider
vocalising your thoughts whenever
possible religious now there's one point
where Kevin is showing is this type
is not saying anything I don't know how
many of us you have the gift of the
ability to read minds
no now because of that we don't have
that gift we need to help our pair to
know where we are going so if you try to
think about vocalizing what you're doing
or what you're thinking for men
typically can get a bit difficult
because we cannot not eat us it takes
time to train yourself to do that I
remember if you if you read the book
pragmatic programmer anyone who read
their before pragmatic programmer okay
yeah so there's this part where they
talk about rubber ducking rubber duckie
is a technique where if you're stuck
imagine you are writing your coat and
you're speaking to a rubber duck just
vocalize what you're doing that
sometimes help you to get unstuck and
when you're vocalizing with your pen
that can be helpful as well right so
later on when you try the pair
programming try this consider vocalizing
a toast and see how it feels if you're
not used to that point number five give
permissions explicitly and upfront
especially a pairing or someone new I
know this among us there are some of us
are people who know each other so that
can be easy but if you're a parent
someone new that person may not know how
you work and you don't know how the
person work you can consider telling
upfront what you're comfortable with
what you're not comfortable with I
remember when I first had I was telling
my partner stop me if I'm too fast well
I was full of ego I thought I could type
very fast that my partner cannot follow
but most of the time you told me you're
too slow okay fair enough but it's
things like this that's helpful you know
at least you know you give your partner
permission if you see me being stuck can
you just jump in feel free to just jump
in that will set up a good context for
you to start pepper running point number
six navigators
watch your drivers back by tracking
reminding things now this really used to
especially we do test-driven development
your partner is thinking about test case
writing a code and when you may realize
what about this edge
case that you need to handle now instead
of disturbing the driver at the point in
time to say so so I've something to
discuss with you and your driveways in
the flow you just jot down that that
path that the thing you need if you feel
that needs to be addressed
and when the driveways reach a logical
point just stop the driver I think we
need to handle this special scenario
that's that's one sort of things that I
find it very helpful in a past when i
pair with someone else points I will
never get us be patient and this we this
comes to hasty Hansen right that the
person is typing mean always be the
fastest the next one is lose the ego and
put on humility this especially true if
you are not used to pay programming or
your parents someone you're not familiar
with all of us fear that we are being
judged right well this person looking
through my shoulder I wonder if I'm good
enough
we always fear that but if you always
have that thinking in mind it's gonna be
very hard to pack you have to learn to
let let go of your ego and put on
humility all of us make mistakes so it's
okay to make mistakes last two things
first take care of your person I gene
Dirty Harry
so not gonna comment more and point
number ten is soft pass often and
logical stopping point one of the reason
why we do pair programming is because of
knowledge spreading you wanna module we
pair someone else that person will also
get the knowledge how many of you guys
should do scrum okay ready to scrum I
assume your screen length is about two
weeks three weeks four weeks okay the
four is the maximum idea if more then
you're not doing scrum if you pair
together and you work through the entire
sprint you kind of lose the benefit of
pepra gramming because you're not
sharing knowledge enough within a spin
you're creating a silo
within the pair for sprint so make have
the program I usually want to speak pass
within the spring itself okay it's
better if you there are options for the
you can split at the point after you do
a check-in you spear someone else or you
can finish a story for example then you
stop pass I think this is one of the
most common problem people like to pair
each other so much that you don't know
so you must you must accurately that
stopping now when it comes to to possess
it in together when you look at a person
you've just decided to pair with how do
you do the pairing early on I was just
talking about attitudes and behaviors
now the mechanics there are generally
three options I know there are
variations but just highlight three the
process time boss time box means when
two persons come together one person
would be writing the tests and writing a
code for X amount of minutes when a time
finish you swap the role so that the the
partner now becomes a one who drives
whereas the other one will just be the
partner that's time box it's up to you
to figure what works for you in terms of
time box some people try the Pomodoro
Technique
there are variations to that the second
way is called fluid fluid is when two
persons work together you can just swap
at any point in time phrase out if
you're stuck the other person just take
over and continue or if you feel that
you have better ideas just take over and
continue just keep swapping there's no
definite time to solve but it's fluid
third one is a ping pong technique where
one person will write a test case then
you pass over to your partner to write
the code that means your partner becomes
a driver now to the code to pass a test
case and this works well if you do TDD
you write a test then your partner
either code the make sure it passed
before you solve the rule later on our
demo review our demo for you the ping
pong method when I pair with a mu and
the last one is really richest of the
above you can always change and if
between different partners some would
prefer different things
try yourself what works so when I'm
sitting with a moon later to avoid this
demo as a spectator sport I want you to
notice something because there are some
things that you know interaction that
you need to pick up and we're doing the
brief of the read what is it
come okay so what do you notice or pick
up from this demo right so I want to
know not this one so I'm just going to
do a demo now I invite ammu come sit
with me
a different
you say hello to me
okay I'm just gonna adjust the mic a bit
okay nice can you hear me can you at
least see our face if not then we may
need to turn on the lights
they can't see the screen they can see
the screen okay
good alright so can you see this
yes it's okay couple into space we are
going to use ping pong for the pairing
session yeah I suggest that are you okay
yes any time if you feel if you want to
take over the machine feel freedom yeah
so let me just give you a debrief
yesterday Kevin ourself we are pairing
on this what counting exercise so we are
writing tests and I got some test cases
passing for the simplest case for
example a single word but then six
o'clock came and we just decided go home
so I just want to pick it up from here
today and since you're available yeah
homie that's to me okay so these are
doing ping pong I thought I saw like
that okay so can I interrupt you yeah
what is the current state of the test
cases that we have are they all passing
yeah I never thought of that
yeah let's see if we understable ground
so there's this run a test oh okay so
one or test is failing
so we see some implementation probably
yeah so there's a case way I have two
sentences repeated twice what I'm
supposed to get to yeah this way I fail
the test case yesterday we went home
are you come for the try now or you want
me right yeah
okay so we're basically missing the
scenario where we need to have towards a
possible solution that I can think of is
I would like to since we're doing it
until anyway yeah maybe I can implement
this fake it till you make it so I
probably select I will check the
sentence okay to be equal to word word
okay and if that is the case shall
return
the frequency for what does that make
sense be honest if the task is pass
yeah okay that's nice sure interest at
that that's guess so now that we have
this two words working I'm thinking of
introducing a different one that should
help us to take a case way I expected
result come on and more than one would
count okay let me show you what happen
Mike yeah
[Music]
so what I was thinking of is just to
sentence with with different word and a
word repeated twice okay in that case is
to return a count of three and count of
one for the non repeat that would is
okay
okay
yeah wait for you to write the sentence
maybe yeah okay so let me just add one
more maybe called another word okay
can I think we would probably be
expecting the count of 2 instead of
Coventry ah yeah yeah all right
that looks more reasonable so in the so
in case of this expectation I would want
to have another and one does that look
good
yeah it sounds good so let's run a test
and we run all the tests first make sure
we are still okay with that
nice alright is it failing based on what
I expect yes defecting towards but we
only have a single one yep
okay I think so now what we need to
check is that because we have different
words I could fake it but solution is
kind of obvious in its way so I would
rather want to break down a sentence
into different words okay and send out
the frequencies from there so look look
through the gray of words that I receive
frequency but I think it would be got
some sort of refactoring so actually I'm
not comfortable running this test yet
could i uncomment this they're growing
change and come back - yeah
so I'll comment this out and what I'm
trying to do here is
I find out what I have in my sentence
you would under spin yourself that's
right yes
so sentence all right
so I'll split it with the space yeah
so I have the words and then
I'll go through each one yep
and now I want to check whether
this word is present inside
no it should be accumulator some saucer
collector right yeah we need something
to collect
does it not check does that mean yes
what does what accumulator make sense or
would you prefer something else yeah I
make sense immediately
so we this accumulator will basically
store the frequency of each defeat an
award yeah so now what I'm trying to
check is
if
the world is already present is to be
presently lying
sorry he's on line five the keys
he shouldn't be sentence right it should
be accumulated right
so if I find that I've checked yeah
what I wanted two ways
incremental frequency for that specific
object there so simulator word Espace
okay if not I wish to initialize it
is that correct I don't think is correct
by you can write a test case and see how
it works yeah
aporia sales yeah because this is to be
a function
I see right
so what should be
let me rename it yeah software so it's
clear us because we are looking at keys
or that's always key yep so I expect the
word to be going
okay
all right test bus okay so let's add a
comment our your the refactor first
because I felt that code just now
especially line 14 sentence but what I
don't do me all right it could be the
cause of acrossing that's returns
America we tend accumulate right so
that's fine
result that we have
oh all right it fails yeah I think
America's acting
sorry what is room so let me show you so
I'm thinking of this and wonder is
because of the plus pass
let's try this
No failed again I think what we're
expecting is there's probably an issue
there is although we have actually
should not be 0 right
oh yeah it should be 1 right it should
be 1 because when the object doesn't
isn't present but you already Ike riding
through it so I think the blood splash
should be fine to be honest let's do
that understand processor
open busses
whooping all right yep
that's a comment our corner yeah let's
write it
Oh puss is it a reasonable sentence
looks like it
okay yeah all right dude it's time to
check in it looks like we have reach a
logical point yeah sure I think I'm good
with it I wouldn't want to refactor this
at this point I'm okay
who do you think in we need to have
another test case or is that sufficient
coverage for now I think it's fine for
now okay yeah okay
thank you let's take a break okay so
what do you guys all serve what happened
or slippery did the quarry so boring
they slept okay sorry let me change the
mic because this is too much feedback
well while I change and making you guys
start thinking
what what do you notice about my
interaction if a bow or his interaction
with me
they were very committed
yeah okay I'm gonna ask me a lot of
questions like shall we do this
are you okay to do this so that is his
style when I pair someone else it could
be different but yes that does a useful
thing to to us immerse just check what
else you know this
I'm psychedlic I could get you straight
away
make sure
yeah that is a good point because
sometimes we jump too fast to so much
mistake because the person especially
the the driver you
he or she may realize it by him or
herself later
so don't know jump so fast what is this
agreement that we started with we come
together what was the agreement that we
we talked about yeah so so we agree on
how we are going to approach the firing
session okay anything else your other
race that I miss in our pairing no good
yeah so we actually check with each
other and whether we are done with the
test and this is the advantage of
pairing as compared to doing TDD alone
we do TDD you don't know whether is time
to stop or not but when you a pair with
you both of you feels that you is a good
time to pretend that's that's a really
good feedback to get it's a good
feedback to know when to stop and he
also asked me about the renaming of a
variable should it be an accumulator
when repair sorry where we want alone
sometimes we come up with some variables
that we think it's clear to the whole
world sometimes it's not having a pair
with you to check that if it's clear for
two persons chances are you be clear for
some other people as well
these are all the advantages that comes
as you work together on that okay so
this uh that's about a debrief for the
demo unless you have any other questions
that you wanna raise
is efficient it saves time eventually
yeah so pay programa is not silver
bullet neither is TDD it doesn't mean
when someone pair you get super results
but if two persons pay you probably get
better result than one person working
alone that's what we are saying now both
of us are total newbies to JavaScript we
don't know much about it probably the
quality of output would not be as well
as as good as it can be but that's okay
because at least is better than one of
us working alone like for example he may
be struggling with putting the function
into the fine he may be doing so many
things that that takes up time just to
find out whereas I can provide the
information say this is a part way with
me so okay now we are coming back to the
paper by exercise I hope you have your
parody and the first thing I need you to
do you can use the same code that you
used earlier for DVD or you can pull
from the same codebase again except for
this time round you do not need to check
in your code right you do not you push
your code with your pen first decide
which approach you wanna do ping-pong
time box of fluent approach beside that
then secondly after that you'll be
working on an exercise make sure you use
the TDD approach for that and what
exercises this is called 99 bottles of
beer who knows this song all right you
guys can sing because I don't know a
thing
the way we are going to do is exercises
unite you need to write a program and
this program when run is going to output
this lyrics these are actually SL lyrics
the song starts with the top is says 99
bottles of beer on the wall 99 bottles
of beer take one down pass it around 98
bottles of beer on the wall and as and
the lyrics continue by reducing by one
okay one bottle of beer reduce second
wise 98 when you see all the three
points here that dot it simply means it
decrements from 98 97 96 so and so forth
until two bottles of beer alright and do
two bottles of beer and when it comes to
two bottles of beer you have to notice
something start to change the word
bottle is singular now as compared to
everything the before it plural and when
it comes to one bottle of beer now this
word becomes singular the the one on top
is puro and this change and this pot
change as well of course you have the
last one which is no more which changes
to no more this whole sentence change
and this becomes plural game clear your
mission should you choose to accept it
is to write a code that dumps all these
texts out you can choose a hard code all
the way from 99 to no more but I don't
think your pay will allow you to do that
alright so let's do the pair pairing
right now try to do pairing and also try
to do TDD stuff of this I'll give you 15
minutes to do that I'll do a time check
review later okay there's no need to
push your foot into
get anymore 15 minutes let's let's stop
here okay let's stop here question how
many of you guys are relieved that the
pairing session is over okay laughing
means your reliever what one comment
before we do that debrief I notice the
way you guys do pairing some of you guys
who have neck pain tomorrow or spine
pain tomorrow because you're in an
awkward position in fact I think
sometimes a driver doesn't know it the
drivers are so comfortable but I never
get this just trying to find a way to
see and for some of you guys the drivers
who are so kind where you share your
laptop the Navigator can see right but a
driver is on what position so this is
one of the things that we need to take
note about when we do pair programming
is the setup of your of your of your
laptop or your tables and all those
things sometimes you don't like it
because it just makes it awkward now
there are some plugins for editors where
you can have two laptops connected
together you can see the code so you can
sit comfortably in front of your laptop
while the other person may make changes
he has see reflected I think visual
studio we just video code has it
IntelliJ should have it as well
the other option is to have your laptop
plug into a common monitor then you have
plugged in an external keyboard to the
laptop so both persons you have two sets
of keyboard two sets of mouse but a
common monitor so these are things you
need to think about when you do pairing
it's good to see you guys at least try
it out but I don't think is sustainable
as per what it is after maybe one two
hours you you'll be so tired now the
other question I have is actually I'm
getting a debrief now mentally wise do
you find it taxing do you find me more
tiring as compared to doing alone how
many you guys feel is more tiring when
you do pairing
okay who finds it less hiring okay Isis
just to be clear is a binary option
hiring or less tiring for those of you
and I don't know why is that but it's
true pair programming can be tiring
that's why when you do pairing it's
always good to take a break
it's better but I remember the first I
do pairing it was about a whole six
hours straight when I first joined a
company I do it
I was totally tired at the end of the
day all right now it's your turn to tell
me what are the some of the challenges
that you face we'll try doing pairing
just now a platform on things I
dimension okay
kevin has a mic so maybe you can just
share what are your challenges just just
raise it
okay true what I did was actually
creating a bit of hype up for you
because you're not at a logical point
with your speed pair so you have to
rethink the context and you're actually
working on a same thing accepted in a
different way that's why I was
suggesting look for a logical point to
speed pair and not do what I do just
know there is a way I do it because one
to create a bit of chaos second is for
you guys to feel how does it feel like
when you were someone else
okay what other feedback do you have
let's say
safe
you know
thank you very much so and that is a
very common thing in fact once I paired
with a guy whose keyboard has no no no
markings it's all black so what you said
is true because I think it's developers
when we coat alone we have our own
customized way of doing it we like a
certain editors in fact one one thing
other thing is we like to cut our own
way brackets where you started a new
line or not the spacing all these things
that come in the picture now pair
programming in extreme programming
context it's a team effort is a team
thing which also means that instead of
just between two developers agreeing in
fact your whole team needs to agree what
is your coding standard what is your
editor they're gonna use how we supposed
to be set up this I list the minimal
things that you you need to have in
order to be comfortable the other way is
I've seen if I'm a curator some plugins
where both your machines can connect
together but you can keep your own
customized way of your editor
so whatever the other guy change right
using the laptop you will be able see
yet you're not constrained by that I
haven't tried myself by seeing it I
think it's not a bad idea to try that
yeah okay sure what else what else do
you guys have to feedback for that on
your Perry experience
how do you feel when you had to switch
pair
of course if your pair is a good pair
you be happier or uses para but how do
you feel when you have someone totally
new coming
no reaction okay okay I'm gonna skip
that their male-female pairing how do
you guys feel
it's okay these are things these are
real real scenarios you will face so
let's talk about it how does it feel
do you do fear is the issue a non-issue
looking at you guys I can see the
females and Museum what do you guys see
no issue
okay that that they were
okay that nough table okay in front of
everybody see no issue Allah inside
Allah Allah I'm kidding
there's a rare common common question
well how did how should we pave is a
different gender but it's not just
within this room as know you should
there's a book called pair programming
illuminated Laurie Williams generally to
other studies of studying people doing
programming right is really not an issue
the only thing you wanna be careful of
is the space between two persons some
are more comfortable together some may
not be that comfortable just be aware of
that I think happens between guys as
well right
sometimes brush another guys hanging a
few it happens okay just be aware of
this guy takes what if two hands touch
it at the same time sometimes go
electracy some that don't have long but
these are things we have to be aware of
maybe one more thing anything else any
other feedback for those who try
different methods of pairing of swapping
time based fluid and at the you guys are
doing time based and ping-pong how do
you feel about different methods
time-base one more really fun
yeah okay
question do you think you can what do
you think that matter will be
sustainable over time let's say you do
this for eight hours the whole day by
stopping No okay so you may want to be
aware of the things they try it may not
be sustainable just switch to some other
way how long do you choose between your
song
two minutes Wow okay you know this thing
about pair programming very early on
when XV started usually people would
swap around maybe ten minutes this more
extremely extremely yeah okay fair
enough if it was for you I I think it's
fine
so this really brief so at this point I
think we have 15 minutes left it's time
to close thank you for participating a
time question I hope you guys enjoy in
fact I know this the level of the bus
level between the first time when you do
TDD as compared to the second time the
second time seems to be more life more
interesting
for those who didn't like pair
programming I hope today at least would
give you some idea on how to make it
better to make it more in job experience
for you just to recap so you spent
almost three and a half hours in this
session but if we don't know what's the
benefit why we're doing it I think we
kind of missed the point so I'd like to
come back here to talk about what's the
benefit of doing test-driven development
and pair programming at the same time
these are just four points the first one
is increased software designing quality
and the reason if you do TDD it helps
you to think through your software that
the code you're writing of course it's
very crystal quality because your test
covers your code to make sure it works
and the consequences of that is you have
lower defects second point you have good
knowledge spread when it comes to pair
programming since most people swap you
have a good knowledge about assistances
being built now what about test-driven
development how does that help us with
good knowledge spread
you're waiting for answer now the way
good knowledge meant is the test Kevin
Raye said earlier you look at a test you
know what is it doing
you know how the core is supposed to
behave that helps us spread the
knowledge as well if your code base but
no test is hard to gather knowledge
because all the logic is you have to
spend a lot of time trying to figure
that out
now because as a good knowledge spread
you reduce single person dependency
problems the kind of problem where you
work with a team you work alone and you
undergo for two weeks holiday in an
island and your team expects you to be
on call because they may call you and
ask you what the code is doing having
doing TDD of a programming it's okay for
someone not to be around because someone
else would know what has been done okay
so that is reducing a person dependency
the third one is it increases
productivity overall TDD generally will
increase productivity pairing it takes
some time until both paths you get into
a flow into a state you may find
sometimes find paths argue hoardings
takes forever and never get resolved
they think this person thinks this
design is good the other person thinks
his design is good so how do you resolve
goes no problem
one way is usually bring it to the team
and discuss with your team what you're
thinking of and it's actually a useful
way to try to resolve issues now because
it increases productivity that team
would move faster and the last point is
it builds courage in teams what do I
mean by that if you change a piece of
code that doesn't have tests you'll be
scared if you're not scared I salute you
personally I'll be scared because I do
not know if I bring anything or not
but if I know this piece of code has a
test coverage by adding functionality
and the test doesn't fail it gives me
courage so that's how TDD helps the
other thing about building courage when
it comes to pair programming is a case
where if you need to face a problem
alone as compared to having someone to
face it together with you
that should help you
in having more courage to face it I
remember there are many years back I was
pairing someone checking the code six
o'clock went home so happy mean I got a
car got production issue so this shows a
TDD imperio vendors are solve all your
problems but affect that at the midnight
12 12 a.m. I have to go back to office I
know my pair would go with me and we
stand you for him that actually
increases my courage in facing a
midnight issue to be worse off that and
because it builds courage in teams it
helps to improve the team morale you you
finally feel that you're looking as a
team again go forward together all right
these are a few points that I personally
have felt after doing TDD and doing pair
programming any thing that you want to
clarify based on this points anything
you're welcome back to be on on your few
that maybe wouldn't work
No yep tricky because the courage can be
policy because you have to trust that
this test it was be written was school
and we need has the functionality so I
think you should check the tests before
you have the courage to say okay I can
add functionalities metals and so on and
so
[Music]
yes I think Kevin Nealon mentioned one
thing is you can write a test that has
100% code coverage that doesn't test
anything I don't know if you guys have
seen it before if you don't believe just
write a unit test write a code but don't
assert anything your unit test you still
get her percent coverage that's not EDD
first of all and yes so in terms of
whether you think the color work or not
here it depends on how well you know the
people around you maybe a Perry the
person before or what time that should
improve in terms of how you feel about
the quality that's being done okay is
there anything you wanna add on this
last point
reflected them maybe this one here is
that she might sit so you have to get
used to
you
yeah thank you I miss out on that so
useful so before we leave before we
close a couple of announcement first of
all if you see the this thing these are
meant for you
gifts notebook pen and this one other
than that this thing called a sharpie is
not meant for you please don't take it
with you and these are not free as well
so don't they give you the other thing
is when you leave I we would really
appreciate your feedback about a session
and what this means is you can write
your feedback on a post-it notes one
feedback purpose it whether it's good or
bad feel free to just whack after you
return it when you leave the room post
it behind the flipchart area see ya the
one a Chris is pointing to they'll be
useful for us to know how to improve the
session that's the first thing second
thing is when you leave if you're
interested to be notified by Paulo about
any events or training events feel free
to drop your name card at the ball
behind at the border
next to the alcohol wipes all right
chris is bringing it up again okay with
that I think we are done good close
enough so thank you very much for
participation and we're so oh we are
supposed to take we're supposed to take
a group go photo so
the communicable feature